qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour le
jour de l'an le réveillon chez
c'est-à-dire à gahler le soir à minuit
oui grâce à la croûte
qu'est ce que vous allez manger des
huîtres famille et c'est tout ce que
vous allez faire pour intéresser à notre
âge oui j'ai eu le plaisir de recevoir
nos enfants en deux petites filles du
tout rien ne sort pas parce que j'avais
bu je peux pas le faire garder que les
vous faire pour le nouvel an bah me
promenais m'amuser rigoler avec les
copains comme d'habitude m'emmerder
comment voyez-vous les 75 je sais pas
réfléchi andré bayle pourquoi bas le
fioul essence et les restrictions le
chômage personnellement bien point de
vue familial et tout pas bien vu mon âge
je la voie d'une façon plus optimiste
que les jeunes parce que
ma carrière est terminée l'heure moins
de souci à me faire pour défendre la fin
de mes jours aussi bien pas plus mal
je vais réveiller avec ma fille sur tout
avec ma fille je ne sais pas exactement
comment voyez-vous 75o très mal parce
que le gouvernement le gouvernement
socialiste s'est beaucoup mieux que j'ai
dit car je pense que ça va aller très
très mal
les affaires ont bien marché cette année
moyen moyen ça s'annonce moins bien pour
le premier de l'an on n'a pas tellement
de commandes
formidable non c'est pas formidable non
comment allez-vous passer le réveillon
wall-e ah bon il faudra se faire cette
chose comme comment voyez-vous 75 très
mal surtout quand on est ouvrier comment
allez-vous passer le réveillon avec des
anciens camarades chez les militaires je
suis toujours optimiste en général alors
je vois s'habille mieux comme on le dit
qu'allez vous faire pour le réveillon
aller à paris jean paris mais bien à
paris qu'à orléans
moi évidemment y a rien en riant comment
voyez-vous l'année 75
moi j'en sais rien jean ouvert après
très très bien ça va s'arranger
on a eu beaucoup de déception beaucoup
de nuits en 74 mais moi j'espère quand
on est très malade on espère toujours
sari
[Musique]